we know that the multiplication of
scalar quantities is commutative for
example five times seven is the same
thing as seven times five and that's
obviously just a particular example I
could give many many more three times
negative 11 is the same thing as
negative eleven times three and the
whole point of commutativity I can ever
say it is that it doesn't matter what
order that I'm multiplying in this is
the same thing as negative eleven times
three or if we wanted to speak in
general terms if I have the scalar a and
I multiply it times the scalar B that's
going to be the same thing as
multiplying the scalar B times the
scalar times the scalar a now what I
want to do in this video is think about
whether this property of commutativity
of the whether the commutative property
of multiplication of scalars whether
there's a similar property for the
multiplication of matrices whether it's
the case that if I had two matrices
let's say matrix capital a and matrix
capital B and matrix capital B whether
it's always the case that that product
the resulting matrix here is the same as
the product of matrix B and matrix a
just swapping the order and I encourage
you so is this always true it might be
sometimes true but in order for us to
say that matrix multiplication is
commutative that it doesn't matter what
order we are multiplying it we have to
figure out is this always going to be
true and I encourage you to pause this
video and think about that for a little
bit well let's just think through a few
things first of all let's just think
about matrices of different dimensions
so let's say I have a matrix here let's
say that matrix a matrix a is a I don't
know let's say it is a s a it is a five
by two matrix
five by two matrix and matrix B matrix B
is a 2 by it's a two by three matrix so
the product a B is going to the product
a B is
have what dimensions so if I multiply
these two you're going to get a third
matrix let's just call that let's just
call that C for now you're going to get
a third matrix C and what are there
going to be the dimensions of C well we
know that the first of all that this
that this product is is defined under
our convention of matrix multiplication
because the number of columns that a has
is the same as the number of rows B has
and the resulting rows and column are
going to be the rows of a and the
columns of B so C is going to be a five
by three matrix a five by three matrix
now what about the other way around what
would be times a B and once again I
encourage you to pause the video so if
you took if you were to take B so let me
copy and paste that and multiply that
times a so I'm really just switching the
order of the multiplication so copy and
paste
so if we take that product right over
there what is that going to be equal to
what is this what is this right over
here going to be equal to well the first
question is is maestra is matrix
multiplication even defined for these
two matrices and when you look at the
number of columns that B has and the
number of rows that a has you see that
it actually is not defined that we have
a different number of columns for being
a different number of rows for a so here
the product is not defined is not
defined so this immediately is a pretty
big clue that this isn't always going to
be true here a B the product a B is
defined and you'll end up with a five by
three matrix the product here B a isn't
even defined so this is already you know
we're already seeing that this is not
not the case that order matters when you
are multiplying when you are multiplying
matrices and to make things a little bit
more concrete let's let's actually look
at a matrix you might be saying oh maybe
this doesn't work only when it's not
defined but maybe it works if if we
always do with square matrices or
matrices where both products are all
always defined in some way or maybe if
they or some other case and so let's
look at a case where we're dealing with
two two by two matrices and see whether
order matters so let's say I have the
matrix let's say I have the matrix 1 2
negative 3 negative 4 and I want to
multiply that by the matrix by the
matrix negative 2 0 0 negative 3 what's
that product going to be 9 once again I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about that well let's think about
let's think it through and we've done
this many times now so this first entry
here is going to be or since you're
going to look at this row and this
column so it's 1 times negative 2 which
is negative 2 plus 2 times 0 so this is
going to be negative 2 and now for this
entry for this entry over here we look
at this row and this column so 1 times 0
which is 0 plus 2 times negative 3 which
is negative 6 and then 4 and then for
this entry we would look at this row and
this column so negative 3 times negative
2 is positive 6 plus negative 4 times 0
which is just positive 6 so you're going
to have positive 6 and then finally for
this entry it's going to be the second
row times the second column negative 3
times 0 0 negative 4 times negative 3 is
positive 12 so fair enough
now what if we did it the other way
around what if we were to multiply what
if we were to multiply negative 2 0 0
negative 3 times times 1 2 negative 3
negative 4 what's this going to be equal
to and as always it's a good idea to try
to pause it and work through it on your
own so let's think about this so
negative 2 times 1 is negative 2 plus 0
times negative 3 so that's going to be
negative 2 so so far it's looking pretty
good then if you have negative 2 times 2
is negative 4 plus 0 times negative
four is negative four so we already see
that these two things aren't going to be
equal but let's just finish it just so
that we have a feeling of completion so
this entry right over is going to be the
second row first column 0 times 1 plus
negative 3 times negative 3 is positive
9 once again doesn't match up and then
finally 0 times 2 is 0 plus negative 3
times negative 4 is is positive 12 so
that one actually did match up but
clearly these two products are not the
same thing the order and with which even
though it's defined you doesn't matter
whether you take the yellow one times
the purple one or the purple one times
the yellow one both of those result in a
defined product but we see it's not the
same product so once again another case
showing that isn't that multiplication
of matrices is not commutative